foreign
Stars across Hollywood are sharing their
well wishes for Madonna
yesterday afternoon Madonna's talent
manager broke the news that the singer
had been hospitalized due to a serious
infection according to her manager
Madonna developed a serious bacterial
infection which led to a several day
stay in the ICU thankfully Madonna is
reportedly on the mend with her manager
stating that a full recovery is expected
currently the singer is still under
medical care but out of the ICU
[Music]
Madonna's longtime friend Rosie
O'Donnell is also sharing a positive
update sharing a throwback photo of the
two of them Rosie wrote she's feeling
good with a thumbs up emoji just four
days before Madonna's Health scare the
singer posted a series of Instagram
photos with the caption the Calm before
the storm Madonna Was preparing to kick
off her celebration World Tour next
month but it will now be rescheduled